[Musique]
il est temps que la
communauté internationale comprenne que c'est un
problème qui doit être traité maintenant,
sinon nous nous retrouverons dans une situation de
rupture, il y aura un niveau élevé d'
insécurité alimentaire aiguë, il y aura des millions de
personnes supplémentaires  cela nécessitera une
aide alimentaire et il nous faudra des années pour
contrôler cette situation
[Musique] [
Musique]
um Samaritan Jamie na kama est le dr.  laraby
a cabeza de Conti c'est vrai toute
l'année mais un accueil extrémiste au
Japon je veux dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le problème que nous avons dans la région c'est
que la saison des plantations va arriver
très bientôt elle va commencer elle va commencer
Avril Avril Mai dans la plupart des pays,
cela signifie que si nous ne parvenons pas à
contrôler la population acridienne pour le moment, l'
impact sur les
plantes à venir sera énorme.
[Musique]